[Music]
today we are thinking about life beauty
and being so once beauty was about
goodness and truth but now we think it
means little more than models products
and outdated art have practical concerns
and the economy of desire made beauty
trivial and expendable or could we
follow Goethe and Kant and cultivate our
aesthetic judgment to enrich our lives
oh it's the goal of living beautifully
it conceits only for the privileged
elite I'd like to introduce our speakers
first Justine Coolatta Justine is the
founder of the public spheres salon and
an expert in German philosophy benson
annie is a philosopher of art and a
professor at the University of Antwerp
and last but not least Sam Roddick Sam
is an activist and artist she founded
the erotic boutique Coco de Mer and
she's presented for BBC arts so the
question they will be responding to
first is is the goal of living
beautifully a conceit of the privileged
elite and we'll start with you Justine
hello everyone yes so I very strongly
believe that it is not I think that
first of all we have to talk about
definitions how I think that popularly
when we talk about beauty now people do
associate it with models and fashion and
everything that I think contorts the
true definition of beauty which is in
the more I see it in the more platonic
sense as a kind of abstract form it's
connected to the good and the true and
something that is a kind of guiding
principle of our life that we find in
many different areas be it in looking at
a beautiful sunset or seeing a beautiful
interaction between two people or
looking at a piece of Arts that somehow
elevates us as as human beings and to me
that is not trivial at all and in fact I
think that's the the essence of morality
is grounded in that kind of conception
of beauty the essence of being a human
is grounded in that conception of beauty
and so I think often times when when Pia
associate beauty with with other things
and they say it's it's not significant
it's not consequential it's because
they're thinking of it in this more
modern sense where it is connected but
I'd like to completely separate the two
because if we confuse them at all we're
talking about something entirely
different so from my perspective my
research is grounded in this idea of the
beautiful soul and this was kind of
grounded in the Enlightenment principles
of you know striving towards rationality
striving towards equality tribe striving
towards kind of scientific truth but
there was also kind of at the the bridge
between enlightenment and Romanticism
and then the play with the emotions and
the significance of feeling and
experiences in the world and encounters
with people these these things were
united in this concept and essentially
the idea of the beautiful soul which we
now would dismiss in the age of Trump I
think to think about the beautiful soul
sounds ridiculous but I think you'll see
more and more that's something that I
think a very pragmatic approach the
world in politics in in in economics in
society has kind of branded as
insignificant we will see with the total
demise of values that this again becomes
very significant precisely because it
holds a kind of more objective truth and
so in relation to this I mean I would
just say that this concept the basic
idea was that you could kind of
cultivate yourself almost like a person
sculpting a sculpture you can sculpt
away the impurities essentially the idea
was in your soul you we often think
about physical health we think how are
you know Bali operates but we never
think about the condition or the state
of our soul and if everyone did that
every day I think it would have huge
implications for how we treat other
humans how we interact in the world are
we living a life of value and meaning
and so a lot of this was thinking about
okay well our individuals actions in the
world a lot of it was thinking about the
subjective you know cultivating virtues
cultivating a kind of sense of self in
relation to others but it was ultimately
directed at the objective a kind of
collective good so it was while it was
very subjective and individualistic it
was for the sake of humanity because the
idea was in line with the kind of con
an idea that enlightenment is you you
know the French Revolution the chaos
that happened in you know something that
was so good but then but then eventually
led to the terror if there's kind of
dogmatic action that's unreflective it
won't lead to any more clarity or truth
it will only lead to chaos and madness
and so the idea was kind of taking up
that continent principle of we each are
kind of a very significant person like
being in the world that is a unit in a
society and if we don't realize our
potential if we don't cultivate latent
potential then we are not being you know
active moral agents and that's so
essential to larger frameworks of
morality so I think so I guess I'm out
of time probably but yeah I think it's
absolutely fundamental in that sense
fantastic thanks Justine that's a really
great start for us Ben sir Thanks so the
question is whether beauty is the
privilege of the elite yes
so I'm my guess is that very few people
would say that it is and I guess you
know that would be a bold position so
I'm gonna take that ball position so I
think that beauty at least in some sense
in some sense of the terms traditionally
understood is the privilege of the elite
and that's why we should not care about
beauty in that sense maybe we should
care about beauty in a different sense
so maybe it's a definitional question so
we're gonna see that I guess later but I
I do want to argue that much of what we
care about in the world of art is not
beauty anymore that may have been beauty
in the 17th century with Lauren's little
landscapes and stuff but not really
anymore that's not why we go to two
exhibitions it's not why we go to the
cinema that's not why we go to the
theater or not we go to concerts what
the reason why we do go to these events
is to get experiences that are really
rewarding for us special kind of
experiences and some of those
experiences are what was being
traditionally described as beautiful but
not all of them are gonna be that so so
I think it in some sense it's been a big
mistake for aesthetics the fosco
discipline to be obsessed with beauty
because beauty is just one aspect of
what we find interesting or exciting
about about art and it would be a good
idea for if you want to understand our
engagement with artworks to to kind of
widen our horizon and to focus on
because disengage with this obsession
with beauty and and focus on various
kinds of experiences of all kinds that's
my pitch thank you um well I'm kind of
interested in the concept of beauty in
how I personally experience beauty but
then also the political interplay that
it has within our lives and then
actually from an economic point of view
where the commodification of beauty
comes in so there these three areas of
beauty that I personally interact with
and I was really thinking about it
because what does the experience of
beauty really feel like and when do you
actually get to observe beauty and what
state are you in
and I think that is a really interesting
question and I wanted to come up with an
example
where actually Beauty shifts and changes
with biorhythms and that sometimes is
from an emotional perspective but then
also through political kind of eras
without with in history what is
considered culturally beautiful also
shifts and you're seeing that kind of
speed up as kind of ascetic styles are
kind of get dumped and put into the
landfill and new ones arise and old ones
get reborn so the way I wanted to
describe my emotional interplay with
beauty was how I can see somebody who's
asymmetrical and very typical I can
immediately find them an extraordinary
example of physical beauty and as I get
to know them various realities of their
characteristics start to paint a hue on
their features that allows me either to
redefine somebody who might be
immediately not very attractive into
somebody who is stunningly attractive
that comes and their aesthetic shifts as
you either emotionally bond or find them
kind of repugnant somebody very
beautiful can shift into a form of
ugliness in front of your eyes so when
you actually have this you can start to
realize that your emotional landscape
actually feeds your perception and that
can be ever shifting all the time and I
think that's a really important
perspective to hold and also when do we
see a beautiful kind of sunset as
beautiful we have to be in a state of
observation because we can walk past
beautiful experiences every day like a
symphony of birds and all we're hearing
is our thoughts or our stresses and we
actually kind of can blank out these
kind of extraordinary kind of feelings
of present nurse because actually
observing beauty requires us to step out
of ourselves and actually be an
observable character now the most
important question is have we changed or
have we commodified beauty and made it
of an economic value there's somebody
who is more beautiful hold a more value
social value and therefore is more
rewarded with in our economic society if
they hold the right features that we can
recognize them with and is somebody who
is ugly penalized for that
but also that also comes in with
actually the history of what we
culturally have defined as beautiful has
always been dictated by the politics of
the wealthy from religion from the the
the color blue that the Virgin Mary was
painted it was illegal for any artist to
use it other than that it was the most
precious color the actual geometrics of
a temple was controlled and you were
kind of kind of physically penalised by
the church if you actually made a church
to dis proportions of the golden mean
and so I think that is also the fact
that actually beauty is about
exclusivity
Kumada Bates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas her III TV
you